what actually has it been like for you
the last two or three years because
you've been doing such great work on
such and so many cool projects can you
take that in or is it sort of just like
you know what I mean yeah
um
no
I don't I don't think I don't think I
have I don't think I
I don't know if I will you know
um there's a part of me that just
just gonna constantly move and shift and
grow and it's kind of like when you grow
the body you know when you're working
out in training you know you realize you
look over there and you've lived at this
amount of weight and then you know one
day you wake up in the mirror and you
look up and your shoulders look
different you know or your your legs
look different or you know things are
things you begin to move differently
um I think I'm Really Gonna understand
what has happened
um
in January March April and May
uh when I get on my next set you know uh
and I can feel the growth of everything
I've done and just internally the next
turn was is really great and it's a part
of our business and I thank God for it
it's really fun to see you know
um but I can take more stock if I when I
go
okay so how am I how's the instrument
playing now you know how strong are we
now yeah sure I have to ask you as a fan
of your work and also I'm just curious
what are you filming in May uh me and
Willem Dafoe I gotta go shoot this film
uh called the man in my basement
uh which is really really really good
it's uh it's not a bit of it it's a
two-hander if he kind of comes in and uh
yeah I literally talked to Willem on
Wednesday of this week so I will be
asking him about this yeah yeah yeah he
and his film just uh premiered that
Berlin inside yeah I'm talking about
he's fantastic I heard yet seeing the
two of you together I'm already uh
Beyond excited but I want to switch back
to Creed for a second obviously and so
I'm curious what do you think would
surprise fans to learn about filming
like a big action a big fight sequence
like in the third Act of this film it's
extremely technical
um extremely Technical and um
well I would probably imagine that I
guess probably the level of emotionality
that's happening in them I mean the the
space I think I talk to people don't uh
think about well I never thought about
it you know uh how electrifying uh the
space is when you're shooting those
things when the stakes are high in the
movie they're also high on set you know
and so the amount of energy that's
pumping you know when when we were
shooting those scenes was uh uncanny you
know it's it's it's different from you
know a film where you know you just have
your hero or just your villain by
themselves you know dealing with
something you've got both of these
characters at the height you know and
it's it was extremely uh everything you
know a very rare everything and I don't
remember any of it but you know yeah
what I'm curious about is you have
consistently delivered to me
um just such fantastic performances over
the last little bit and I'm curious and
I think we talked about this a little
bit at Sundance but how have you sort of
changed as an actor because I you told
me like with the harder they fall you
just stayed in that you know that zone
while the with covet but like how have
you changed have you been able to relax
a little bit when you're on set now or
are you still as intense as you used to
be
um probably more so intense yeah
probably more so intense I mean it
always depends on the role as far as
intense but it the there's a certain
frequency you know and that that has to
do with my pedagogy and belief as an
actor you know there's a certain my
Balinese uh troop they talk about this
thing called bachobatu
is an energy that is about uh when you
step on the stage right when the topang
dancer steps on the stage which is about
in his dance uh the energy that they're
supposed to or that they're trying to
conjure is that the audience thinks
they're going to be eating
either we yeah uh so they they should
it's almost like a wild animal is there
and so in honoring that right you have
to work at a certain level to or you can
talk about the clown work we try to get
to a red zone right before you enter
this into the space all of that is still
and it's gonna do with me it's just got
to do what I've just how I how I work
you know um and yeah there are times in
the in between where
here's the thing bro I'm always kind of
chilling you know I've always kind of
chilling until it's go time you know and
then when it's go time you go you know
and so it is important to uh for me to
relax you know but but you can only do
the work properly in our in a relaxed
state so
um
no it's always it's the same you know
um the same but different if that's
helpful yeah I sort of I uh but I'm just
gonna I really mean it man I'm so
impressed with your work the last little
bit
um well for everything you've done and I
just wish you nothing but the best it's
always good to see you man